y
[Aplausos]
[Música]
todo comenzó aquí en esta maquinita
cuando yo tenía 10 años
algunos tal vez las reconocerán de
inmediato otros les parecerá
completamente novedosa pero esa edad un
niño generalmente no sabe cómo funciona
y yo no lo sabía en absoluto
y la cosa es que fue aquí donde descubrí
que a veces los problemas se complican
mucho más de lo que nos esperábamos cómo
salir a jugar en el parque y tratar de
remendar mis pantalones rotos hasta
meterme dentro de ella y tratar de
reconstruirla para ocultar nuestras
basuras y si en esa maquinita que vieron
es donde aprendí a utilizarla y lo hice
observando a mi abuelita con su destreza
manejarla o incluso a las expertas de la
casa cuando por fin aprendí el mecanismo
descubrí dos cosas súper sencillas la
una era que tengo un pésimo gusto para
la moda y la otra era que me interesaba
muchísimo saber cómo funcionaba esa
maravilla que los adultos manejaban con
tanta destreza
cierta vez regresé del colegio en la
tarde y estaba tratando de remendar una
camisa
tenía algo en la cabeza que no me podía
sacar debía encontrar la manera perfecta
o la excusa para decirles a mis papis
que me había ido mal en las pruebas
sociales
también tenía una prueba de literatura
y en esa de élite me fue mucho mejor
así que sentado en la maquinita que era
mi estudio personal para juegos o
también para estudiar en verdad
me puse a pensar porque me va tan bien y
tan mal en sociales en sociales tenía
que memorizar el nombre de las 35
parroquias del cantón cuenca y evita en
cambio crear una historia y la verdad es
que a mí me gustaba mucho más de eso de
crear una historia de hacer con algo tan
simple y común como esto que puede
parecer insignificante para algunas
personas historias fantásticas que para
mí era encontrar problemas encontrar
respuestas y encontrar soluciones en una
historia principal y personal con el
tiempo mi profe de literatura solía
decir que el problema es el motor de la
historia y no les engaña al principio
uno no lo entiende bien pero con la
práctica lo hice
y fue un cuento corto que me pidieron
hacer en literatura lo que me lo
demostró en este cuento
vemos una evolución de esa maquinita
ahora aquí se sentaba a una vieja bruja
no era mi abuelita
si ella remendaba los pantalones y
además todas las prendas del rey no
componían los vestidos más hermosos que
se puedan imaginar pero además podrías
ver el futuro en ella porque los hilos
guardaban los nombres de las personas
que tú te encontrarías
cuando llegó el día de la exposición y
yo rezaba que no me tocase
y mi profe me hizo preguntas que no
tenían nada que ver con la maquinita
no me las esperaba ninguna y no tenía
una respuesta inmediata me dijo y qué
son los viajes en el tiempo
y qué es eso de la inmortalidad cuál es
el origen de las brujas no tenía una
respuesta pensé que se burlaba de mí al
comienzo a veces pensamos eso pero no
fue así y lo descubrí luego
la cosa fue que yo me llevé la duda de
la escuela de casa y encontré a mi
experta favorita número uno que era mi
mami
y le dije
un llamamiento que piensa respecto de el
destino
yo ya iba con la pregunta y me encontré
con nota le respondió con un cuento
tiene un cuento o cheverísimo el cuento
de las brujas gracias
son seres mitológicos que son capaces de
ver el destino en los hilos que forman
cada una de nuestras vidas incluso los
de oro
se imaginan que me gustó tanto y esa
época el google iba a paso de tortuga
así que fui a leer y releer y tuve
suficiente tiempo como para descubrir
que las cosas se iban complicando en esa
historia y que habían muchas cositas que
yo no sabía
pero sin embargo me gustó tanto tanto
que decidimos mezclar la historia de las
brujas
ahora ya no era mi abuelita con
mi máquina de coser
y tenía que afrontar algo nuevo
a los 12 años
esa clase de cosas es aquí
pero yo tenía que hacerlo con expertos
de mi edad con mis primos o mis amigos
no sabíamos mucho pero le íbamos dando
una respuesta
pasado una semana sí una semana y llegó
a mi mamá
y como siempre hace sin tocar llegó y me
dejó en la tablita de la maquinita jamás
salí de aquí era mi estudio dejo en esa
tablita de ahí un libro un libro de
ciencia ficción pero no era cualquier
libro ese libro le pertenecía a un
adolescente
y me gustó tanto y estuvo tan chévere
que dije bueno y como hizo para que sea
tan tan atractiva la historia así que
por primera vez en mi vida leí el
prólogo
y me encontré de cara con julio verne
en eso de ir pensando mientras las
noches pasaban descubrí que él hacía lo
mismo que yo
se sentaba una noche a ver qué
encontraba pero él cogió una bala y
dentro de la bala se dio cuenta que
podía viajar a la luna y no solo ir a la
luna sino también regresar a la tierra
bingo eso era y no era cualquier cosa
sino que se trataba de dar aspectos
fantásticos a la historia pero además de
la fantasía tú debía ser capaz de
entregar tantos datos específicos y
científicos como para hacerla cierta
bueno yo estaba en ones no tenía 12 años
era un nuevo reto y decidí cambiar la
historia de la maquinita porque eso de
consultar el destino es
propio de las películas y yo no tenía
manera de justificar la así que dije de
pronto puede consultar las memorias de
la gente y maquinita era capaz de
meterse en las cabezas de cada una de
las personas y así darte los nombres
pero en esos de los psíquicos si había
un poco de estudios y de seguro alguien
me respaldaban que yo no sabía nada al
respecto
y aquí fue donde comenzó el viaje más
gracioso de mi vida con esa alegría de
haber triunfado y encontrado una
respuesta que cambiar me embarqué al
milenio un plazo
si en el milenio de tanto observar se me
fue el ojo y me gustó una chica
y créanme si es que aún no lo sabe no lo
sabrán es eso de verse ya te queda
viendo se ríen se esconden se miran y
tratan de decirse algo que no se dice
y yo iba cada semana sólo para verle a
ella pero pasaba escondido detrás de la
columna porque no tenía la suficiente
valentía de decirle lo que yo sentía así
que me dije ya nada verán le voy a
escribir un buen una carta
y dije facilito me senté de nuevo en la
maquinita que era mi estudio y me puse a
comparar sus ojos con estrellas
ha sido más profundo y cursi de lo que
uno piensa incluso gaste más hojas que
tratando de escribir el cuento de la
escuela y fue como quién
ya nada si es que no escribo lo que
siento voy y le hablo este mismo viernes
me derrotó me tocó hablar no podía
encontrar lo que yo sentía por ello
estaba un poco confundido
pero le hablé y le di la castilla y
aunque no decía mucho le gustó tanto la
cartita que se hizo mi novia
fue tan chévere esa historia de amor esa
experiencia que yo decidí mezclarla con
el cuento que tenía al comienzo un
cuento que para que lo sepan tenía que
presentar fin de año como examen
y ese cuento que tratará de máquinas de
coser de brujas y ahora tenía tintes de
amor y novela
era una maraña
pero
ahora yo tenía que ser un experto
magia ciencia
en cosas de amor
a los doce uno no se lo espera a veces
te confunde más de lo que crees
llegué era el día de presentar el libro
supuesto libra tenía 40 hojas y se lo di
a mi profe obtuve la calificación de
inmediato la borre y se la regalé a mi
enamorada
le di la historia de la que ella formaba
parte
y tal vez esa fue
porque si bien ahora no sé dónde estará
esa historia
comprendí que tenía que escribir laden
tenía mucho de mí
a los 15 años y en ese afán de tratar de
volver a escribir mi historia
me encontré con
esto de aquí me había quedado dormido
después de la clase de filo de filosofía
y despierta en una cueva como estas
imagínense no de lo más raro esos sueños
pero todos eran viendo hacia la pared
que estaba iluminada por esa fogata que
ven ahí y creíamos que esos objetos como
este caballito que están ahí
y la verdad es que eran las cosas
ciertas yo también lo creía
estábamos encadenados y lo más fresco
incluso teníamos comida
en el próximo sueño
pero en el próximo sueño
después te y ahora faltaba gente a mi
alrededor
y esas personas se habían ido habían ido
a toda prisa ya dónde fueron
descubrí que regresar y traían nuevas y
buenas respuestas
ellos se encontraban afuera
viajaron hasta la luz como el señor que
está allá afuera
y pensábamos que eran lunáticos que eran
soñadores y optimistas que no pegaban en
el mundo
pero me llamó la atención saber cómo
podría seguirles así que lo hice una
primera vez pero tuve miedo
de sentado y temerosos
tuvieron que pasar varios años para que
me atraviese a salir de ella
y ese libro que en un comienzo a mis 12
tenía
ahora
de 300
pero tenía dentro de sí una historia
discreta y distinta
de cómo había hecho yo para encontrar
tantas respuestas a mis problemas
personales
cuál fue la manera correcta
en la que podía justificar las cosas y
brindar mis soluciones
les voy a contar algo
cuando ustedes salen de esa cueva aunque
corren muchos peligros el más grande de
todos es
tienes miedo pero cuando vuelves de ahí
y esto fue lo que hice que resumirá un
poquito toda esa historia de amor y
tragicomedia que les muestro
comenzamos con el problema todos tenemos
algo que nos molesta
y ese problema es lo que debemos
identificar
tenemos que observarlo y ser capaces no
solo deben saber de qué se trata sino
también de interesarnos
tenemos que arriesgarnos y cuando nos
arriesgamos encontramos las primeras
respuestas que a veces no tienen nada
que ver con el problema o nos llevan a
otros pero son muy buenas
luego vamos a la investigación como lo
hice un principio con mi mami y luego
con el google
la investigación me llevó a encontrar
aún más respuestas y aún no solucionaron
el problema
imaginación si es que no hay quien te dé
una respuesta tu puedes crear algo que
no existe
a veces regresas de la caverna
y luego pasa la aplicación de lo que
encontraste ya pesar de que yo tenía un
factor ficción fantasía que me ayudaba a
encontrar esas respuestas al final
terminé encontrando una solución a ese
problema que encontré al principio
aportó a muchos
es un círculo vicioso que se vuelve
apasionante
y es aquí donde yo les invito
a formar parte de este deporte extremo
que es eso de ir en busca de respuestas
pero no importa la edad que tengamos
pueden tener 5
y atreverse a compartirlas
preguntas
[Aplausos]